I've already introduced you to shared memory synchronization.
Lock is a primitive and particularly the mutual exclusion
lock is a primitive that is used ubiquitously
in writing shared memory parallel programs to protect data
structure so that one thread can exclusively modify
the data and release the lock so that another
thread can inspect the data later on and
so on. And similarly, barrier synchronization is another synchronization
primitive that is very popular in scientific programs and
we have covered both of these in fairly great detail
in talking about what the operating system has to
do in order to have efficient implementation of locks as
well as barriers. Now the up shot is, if
you are writing a shared memory program, there are two
types of memory accesses that are going to happen.
One type of memory access is the normal reads and
writes to shared data that is being manipulated
by a particular thread. The second kind of
memory access is going to be for synchronization
variables that are used in implementing locks and barriers
by the operating system itself. It may be
the operating system, or it could be a user
level threads library that is providing these mutual
exclusion locks, or barrier primitives, but in implementing those
synchronization primitives, those algorithms are going to use reads and writes
to shared memory. So there are two types of shared memory accesses
going on in the execution of a parallel program. One is access
to normal shared data and the other is access to synchronization variables.